hello and welcome to the 2015 Ansel
charting tutorial within Python I'm at
plot live where we left off we're just
kind of arranging and coloring our chart
a little bit to make it look a little
better than it was looking so we're
going to go ahead and continue in that
we're going to kind of edit around on
this Mac the email and then after that
we'll be doing one more thing that
actually will change the functionality a
little bit but I think you'll like what
we do so so let's go ahead and fix up
our MACD close out of that and scroll
down to where we've done the Mac these
stuff a little bit okay fill color I
think that will leave the fill color the
way it is and down here let's add some
dollars let's say color equals and we'll
do number four ie 6fd and we'll say the
line width equals two and then here
we'll just do color you want ad f9 and
line width will be one now the next
thing I wouldn't mind doing let's see
let's go ahead and add that text here as
well like we did on the other one so
basically the same thing we'll do x2 dot
text in fact we'll just copy and paste
copy that come down here
dot text same thing only this time we're
going to change it to be mat D 12 26 9
we still wanted to wind at the top the
only thing different here is going to be
we make that a x2 and that's good let's
see what we're looking at now and let's
get rid of this let's see what we've got
now cool so that's up there it's kind of
getting overlapped a little bit but I
still like it there better than on the
side but you can do whatever you want
again the colors I think are pretty good
happy about these colors I don't know
what the heck to do with this line maybe
like a light gray or something let me
try that
scroll up let's do that see what that
looks like I don't know I have no idea
what to do about that
try this c1 f9 f7 I just have no idea I
don't know that looks ok I'll just leave
it there I'll play with it later you can
do whatever the heck you want I just
can't make up my mind let's see I think
now what we want to do is shrink the
amount of digits here obviously there's
way too many they're kind of overlapping
each other so we definitely want to do
that so let's go down to a x2 and what
we want to do is a x2 dot y axes that
set underscore major on your score
locator and we want to use M particular
dot Max and locator and then here you
can specify how many you want to show up
so we'll just say like 5 right and then
we're gonna go ahead and prune the
uppers up and because we're doing that
we connected this and we'll just delete
that commented out title run this okay
so now this actually looks pretty good
I'm pretty happy with this chart now I'm
starting to like this line as well so
maybe I'll stick with it so I think as
far as like editing the chart and the
way it looks I think this will do for
now
now the next thing I think that we
should do and I think that would be kind
of nice is like the way that we're
plotting this is actually from data on
our computer but you can pull this data
off Yahoo's API and you can just do it
like whenever you want with whatever
stock you want so wouldn't it be kind of
nice if we can use this functionality
with any stock and like all we would
have to do is like just type in the
stock ticker and then boom it graphs it
for us right like online there's a lot
of websites that that's all they do
right they just kind of reference maybe
Yahoo's API and draw the graph for you
that you specify what
as you want so now you can kind of just
do that yourself and it's actually quite
quick so that's the next thing that
we're going to do so that way you know
we can generate this chart with any
stock and we could do two years three
years ten years whatever just remember
if you do ten years that the period will
actually be a little different right it
won't actually be fourteen days it'll be
probably more like 28 days or something
like that but the period between each
you know plots basically so in the next
video that's what we're going to do
we're going to kind of make this chart
work with any stock and we're not going
to reference our file on our computer
anymore it's gonna actually reference
the Yahoo API directly so if that sounds
like something interesting to you then I
suggest you continue on in the next
video as always thank you for watching
thanks for your support subscriptions
and until next time